wir reden über die aktuelle energiekrise
und sehr zu recht wir haben aber auch
eine klimakrise vor uns in berlin wo wir
gerade sitzen jeweils vier grad kälter
von 20.000 jahren als 40 meter
eisschicht die nordsee gab es nicht die
osthälfte nicht genannt war keiner insel
nur minimal so ein gefühl zu geben wie
stark die veränderungen sind wenn die
temperatur wirklich steigt das ist ja
20.000 jahre gedauert dieser
temperaturanstieg wir sind jetzt in 200
jahren bei demselben temperaturanstieg
weshalb die hälfte der menschheit kann
nicht mehr da leben wo sie lebt hamburg
geht verloren halb schleswig holstein
geht verloren wir können nicht die eine
krise bewältigen und direkt in die
nächste krise schlittern deswegen wird
es notwendig sein
beim thema vermeidung von co2 sie
lächeln so gar nicht lustig weiter voran
zu kommen und die die
die aufmerksamkeit hat die weltweite
aufmerksamkeit ist noch nämlich sowohl
auf diese krise auf die wir uns wirklich
vorbereiten müssen wahrscheinlicher ist
als der black
ich habe gelächelt weil sie mich einmal
dieser neubau erinnert haben und da ist
natürlich optisch überhaupt das ist ein
lächeln gebracht ich habe wirklich nicht
aus deswegen weil die vorstellung hat
sich leider zum lächeln bewegt hätte ich
die augen zugemacht und ihre stimme wer
an als hätte ich aber dieser neubau
erkannt die frage die ich mir gerade
stelle ist ihre these ist ja energie und
klimakrise müssen gemeinsam behandelt
werden ja wie weit würden sie denn für
das klima gehen also wie weit sollten
wir gehen um das klima zu schützen weil
das ist ja natürlich eine abwägung das
ist natürlich eine abwägung wir werden
jetzt momentan und kohlekraft ja nicht
herumkommen aber wir sollten natürlich
sagen dass wir weniger abschalten wir
müssen vor allen dingen einen weg finden
der die transformation
wirtschaftspolitisch aushält weil die
welt wird uns ja nicht folgen in einem
weg bei der wir einfach nur sagen wir
verzichten das mag ja in deutschland
noch nicht allein auch nicht als
weltklima retten leben aber wir können
mit technologie und
mit der mit dem nachweis dass man
trotzdem eine wohlhabende
wohlstandsgesellschaft bleiben kann dann
nachweis erbringen dass andere dagegen
ich sagen das wird sowieso in zehn
jahren der politische diskurs anders
sein weil der klimawandel ja schon
spürbar ist also in spielen wie er
selbst in deutschland und deutschland
ist ein land das relativ weniger
betroffen ist als andere länder sie
spüren ist in russland weil der
permafrost taut sie spüren dass an der
trockenheit in china sie spüren dass an
den wärmeentwicklung in indien ihre
forderung der was ist die lösung
die lösung ist co2 um jeden preis
vermeiden so schnell und so steil dass
heißt wie weit würden sie dagegen also
ich wir sollten die transformation so
machen dass wir die wirtschaft in die
lage versetzen so schnell wie möglich
doch das sind doch irgendwie muss ich
sagen phrasen weil genau das was man
gemacht hat zuerst aus der atomkraft
einer weitgehend co2 frei
energie quelle auszusteigen dann später
erst aus cola um auf erdgas zu setzen
erdgas jetzt auch co2 frei weniger als
kohle das stimmt jetzt sind wir
gezwungen wieder voll auf die kohle zu
gehen also die schmutzigste aller
energiequellen und sie sagen irgendwie
atom finden sie aber eigentlich auch
nicht die lösung
irgendwas wird man machen müssen und ich
glaube schon dieser plan den wir bislang
gegangen sind hat uns beim wall street
journal jedenfalls
die die kritik eingebracht dass wir die
dümmste energiepolitik der welt machen
wir sind noch nicht nur co2 mäßig gut
auch schon vorher ukraine krise nicht
wir waren von den kosten vollkommen aus
dem ruder gelaufen wird der energiewende
so wie wir sie gemacht haben macht sie
uns selbstverständlich kein land nach
wir sind kein roboter im gegenteil sind
abschreckung und das kriegen wir jetzt
auch überall auf um die ohren gehauen
dass wir uns selber denn es ist nicht
nur putins schuld sondern dass wir uns
selber auch in einer solche zwickmühle
begeben haben und wir geworden und
deshalb meine ich wir müssen
ich finde es ist auch das ja ich finde
genau das waren ich habe das auch schon
länger gesagt hier bei uns der
bundesrechnungshof hat ja auch gesagt es
ist kein einziges ziel erreicht worden
und die kosten aus dem ruder gelaufen
das waren oder solange ich meine tante
ich ja aber die sache ist wir können
jetzt in dieser akkus situation müssen
wir erst mal die
versorgungssicherheit das heißt
überhaupt das angebot ausweiten da
müssen wir auch auf kohle setzen so
schmerzhaft das ist aus klimapolitischer
sicht aber wir müssen uns auch ehrlich
machen all diese pläne die schon ihre
regierung vorher gemacht hatte also von
merkel die regierung also die die
unionsgeführte regierung aber jetzt die
ampel auch wieder vollkommen naiv auf
einem blatt papier macht das alles noch
funktionieren ausstieg aus kohle
endgültig 2030 alle sagen wir haben die
fachkräfte nicht es dauert ein windkraft
radja eben aufzubauen bis zu fünf jahre
im durchschnitt
die
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren sind
solange die leute wollen ist hier fragt
frau sie haben gar nichts weiter daran
oder meinung die wir hier nicht machen
wie wir eben co2 abspaltung die es gibt
jetzt
die antwort aber die technische antwort
sehen sie die gefahr nicht dass die
erwärmung uns ganz andere probleme und
ganz anderen so
die anklage die die eine frage ist gibt
es diese gefahr und ich halte diese
gefahr für serial und deswegen müssen
wir eine menge tun die zweite für die
antwort wie bitte wenn es die gefahr
gibt aber die klimakrise
wir haben ganz sicher in der
vergangenheit fehler gemacht auch die
frage wie die eeg-umlage gemacht haben
diese unbeteiligt ihrem mann es geht ja
nicht darum dass ich das vergangene
verteidigen sondern sage was machen wir
in der zukunft also erstens sind wir
offensichtlich wir beide jeweils
eigentlich es gibt diese regal reale
gefahr und die ist sehr groß und auch
viel wahrscheinlicher als der blackout
deswegen müssen wir uns darauf
vorbereiten dass der eine these und die
zweite these ist müssen natürlich
rational vorgehen ich bin für den strick
betrieb der atomkraftwerke
offensichtlich ist vernünftig dass zu
machen wir werden auch noch andere dinge
machen müssen ist nur atomkraft ist
jetzt viel neuer atomkraft das dauert so
lange so lange habe gar nicht zeit diese
energiekrisen
das ist einzel freitag an vorerst mit
dem weil sie alle argumente aus ich
möchte die alle hören aber ganz kurz der
junge
blackout ist weniger wahrscheinlich
wie nehmen sie denn das war ich merkte
dass die klimakrise ist die klimakrise
ist eine fake krise wenn man sich die
daten ansieht und nicht die prognosen
des eee pc
dann gibt es gar keine klimakrise
sondern da gibt es eine klimaveränderung
die hat es auch immer schon gegeben und
ich sollen ihre dienstzeit ich zitiere
ich jetzt gerne mal den herrn professor
fahren holte er war gestern jetzt ein
wunderbares buch geschrieben
unerwünschte wahrheiten und das sind
alles belegte fakten die pcc ist eine
politische organisation die behauptet
das auf rechenmodellen da sind kaum noch
wissenschaftler darin das meiste sind
politiker und irgendwelche leute
jedenfalls das sind alles
prognosemodelle und die wissenschaftler
sind sich einig dass man mit prognosen
prognosen machen kann aber nicht
unbedingt recht hat und alles was bisher
prognostiziert wurde ist nicht
eingetreten ist ja ist ein warmes ja
letztes jahr war es aber ein sehr
feuchtes jahr und wenn man sich die
langzeitdaten ansieht dann wird mit 30,2
grad wärmer in 100 jahren dass so eine
anstieg hat es in der
menschheitsgeschichte oder nicht nur
direkt erdgeschichte menschheit wie
sowieso nicht sie haben vier grad haben
wir 20.000 jahre gebraucht
dann sehen sie das ist alles ergeben hat
unter cod
verantwortlich und
24 grad führt dazu dass die nordsee
flutet die vorher eine landverbindung zu
england war das heißt wirklich grad
wirklich veränderung dieser veränderung
müssen wir es als eine behauptung dass
wir viel grad kriegen das ist ja genau
so werden ein bestand der stand der
wissenschaft das ist mir das ist nicht
das wesentliche
argument es gibt diese anderen meinung
auch aber es ist nimmt sich eine
mehrheitsmeinung der und es ist
also das heißt ja dann immer dass das
ist so ähnlich wie der koran debatte
also ich finde man kann
unterschiedlicher meinung sein aber ich
denke die die mehrheit und es ist
letztlich auch
diese dieser ansicht setzt sich durch
und ich glaube auch man sollte also man
wenn man sich nicht darauf einlässt dann
hat man eher ein problem roland ort nur
ich glaube wir kommen ja mit unserem
bisherigen haben wir für das weltklima
nichts gewonnen das muss man da zu sehen
dass wir müssen ausreden wir müssen es
so machen dass wir mit anderen zusammen
dann eben aus diesem co2 ausstoß
rauskommen aber nicht wenn wir unsere
wirtschaft kaputt gemacht haben sind wir
ein weiterer probleme aber eben es nutzt
nichts sondern wir können mit technik
einen größeren effekt haben wir indem
wir eben in den wesentlichen bereichen
dabei sind wir sind bei der kernkraft
nicht mehr dabei wir sind bei co2
abspaltung nicht dabei es wäre gut wenn
wir mit grünem wasserstoff künftig vorne
mit maschinen ist es keineswegs klar
also das sind eigentlich die lösung und
nicht irgendwie ein recht naives
programm wie wir hier ganz schnell
aussteigen selber sauber werden aber ich
habe mich da der strombedarf irgendwie
auch dreckige quellen aus dem ausland
setzen das ist heuchlerisch